i want to ask you guys a question which
is
um i've never liked wearing a baseball
cap
okay yeah me either i don't like
baseball caps i don't think they fit my
face or my head when i put a baseball
cap on it makes my face look swollen and
fat it accentuates
the sort of cherubic nature or bloated
nature of an irish fellow's head so i
don't like it i don't like a baseball
cap and so um but what i discovered a
long time ago was that when i do
whenever i do a bit for the show or a
sketch did you just look at your watch i
got it you just looked at your watch
david hopping just looked at his watch
in the middle of it i was faking i got
it it buzzed no it didn't buzz i'm
hearing it making sure that the silence
it was silenced so that it wouldn't
interrupt that's the most rudest thing
that i just said that's the most rudest
thing that is the rudest thing i'm so
sorry yeah i'm in the middle of uh
creating my art i'm jackson pollock i've
got two tubes of paint and a brush and
i'm splattering it all over the place
it's going to be in moma and then right
about that this podcast is the
equivalent of a jackson park
well it depends on how you feel about
jackson pollock i'm just saying the
audio is equivalent to the vision okay
my point is
that i'm a beloved american treasurer i
would say trade
treasure you know
sometimes i like to mispronounce the
word on purpose to give the the podcast
a little more life i think i'm a
treasurer an american treasure and uh
and and i think that uh
that when i'm making my magic and you
look at your watch listen i give sona a
hard time all the time i've never seen
her look at my watch okay when i'm
making my mind magic i just want to say
it i felt it start to vibrate so i was
afraid i was getting a call and was
going to silence it just take it off
from now on okay why don't you put it in
a i'm going to have a lead box mate like
i'm taking it off right now okay can you
throw it outside you open the door and
throw it outside on the floor do i have
to please david you should know that we
do offer exit therapy on all of these
sessions where anyone who's a guest or a
co you know sidekick gets to go into
complementary therapy it's from human
resources please back to i want to hear
about the baseball caps yes back to what
i call
my word magic uh i don't like a baseball
cap i don't think it looks good on me
and it frustrates me that that became
de rigueur clothing for everybody every
man has to have a baseball cap and
everywhere i go i see guys in their 30s
40s 50s 60s wearing a baseball cap and i
think it looks stupid now i've done a
lot of sketches in my day being a
comedy veteran and occasionally i would
have to wear a cowboy hat and i would
realize i look [ __ ] good in a cowboy
hat i really think i do
and i know you're thinking oh no he
doesn't i do i look good in a cowboy hat
so today
i noticed from years ago i did a remote
in texas and someone gave me a really
cool cowboy hat and i put it on
and i like it but i think people think
i'm doing a bit when i'm wearing the
cowboy hat but i just like the way it
works so my question for you david and
also for you matt is can i pull off a
cowboy hat no i'm trying to put it on
pull off the headphones here's the
problem i just put it on i just put i
forgot i was wearing headphones and i
put it on on top of my headphones
look at that that's the stupidest thing
i just put it on on top of my headphones
i also love that i built up to a big but
i'm going to put this on and you're
going to see and here we go clunk
headphones
i don't even want to see it the proper
way you don't oh come on hold on hmm
i do agree that you can pull that off
better than a baseball cap be honest
what do you think and matt i want you to
be honest what do you think i think it
looks good but i think you got to [ __ ]
it back on your head a little bit it was
a little like you know ranch hand when
you want to be kind of roguish playing
so you want it to be if but if i put it
back too far
i look
like it looks like i'm doing a bit
no i don't think so i don't think you
need to go that far but just a little
bit because i'm putting my headphones on
so that yeah um it takes a little
confidence to [ __ ] it back a little bit
that you're at ease like a cowboy yeah
that's nice you got a little bit of luck
of your bangs coming out uh oh
i'm getting a no from some people on
this uh it only comes down that far when
you're sleeping you know when you you
kind of put it over your eyes to catch
40 wins all right i like the fact that
he never takes it off i don't trust i
don't trust that you have my best
interests at heart matt i don't i don't
[Laughter]
you want me to wear it and look like a
fool i think you should keep the
headphones on when you wear it yeah i
will i'm going to start wearing
headphones even out in the world
headphones that have a long cord that
aren't attached to anything gets the
word out on the podcast and then i put
uh
i put this on top of it and it sits on
top of my head the listener should know
that the the bar that goes over the
headphones is super thick so this cowboy
hat is resting inches above the top of
his head it is yeah it is a western
yamaka right now it is just it's perched
at the very top
you have to keep super still so it
doesn't fall off like you're wearing a
neckbreaker that's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna walk around
and
have this thing on the top of my head
and you know i know it's a visual joke
but i'm sure we'll get this out on the
internet you'll see you can go on the
sights and the clicks and the clacks and
you who and yahoo and hulu and you'll
find it um by the way do i know the
business or do i know the business you
really know it uh but this is this is my
new look you even move different well
yeah
you're afraid it's gonna fall off yeah
it's yeah it is basically just resting
on top of three inches of thick rubber i
don't know why we're using the
headphones that people used you know in
korea to communicate with the
battlefield but
i do want to if you see me out in the
world and i'm i'm hard to miss but if
you see uh someone that looks like jane
lynch wearing a big cowboy hat that's me